the first pigskin was somewhat different from the
ones we see today but it was used the same way at
the stone ball in the original skin game touchdown
sparks the cheering section my my the game is
getting out of hand looks as though the football
is winning here's a ball game that never makes the
sports of Ages these guys aren't saving strength
burlap balls are tied with twine then doused in
oil as it gets dark the boys light up the oil
silk wads and begin playing great balls of fire
to qualify this competition a man has to be a
real hothead carefree college cut-ups boy meets
ball ball bounces boy in this contest everybody
is on the ball or you might say the ball is on
everybody this game was invited to keep shirt
makers happy the idea is to push that giant ball
across the other fellows goal line without getting
trampled at that the losers go down to the sea or
a duckie back on terra firma once again we find
the members of the sunday drivers association
playing a little auto polo as you can see the
fall is incidental confusion is the key word
say there's that guy who blows his horn when
the light changes take that with sirens wailing
the fire engines Rumble out of the firehouse
phone for action on the scene hoses are coupled
and water hisses into the air and a ball it's a
diversion called hose ball and the firemen love it
this is one sport where the spectators don't fight
for a front-row seat you know the old
saying you're all wet it began here
football practice on the beach scrimmaging in
the sand gives the players lots of grit and
what's more they're ready to play in any kind
of weather including flood conditions but when
it comes to their aerial attack they're really
off the ground wait'll you see them in action
and here they are after that
session in the Florida sunshine
they are raring to go looks as though
springboard practice really pays off
making a football did you know that there
are seven different kinds of football there's
American Australian Canadian Gaelic rugby soccer
and six man football each with different rules one
game at a time please welcome to the International
rugby match in Europe pomp and ceremony attend the
entrance of the players in fact the whole affair
is attended by a crowd of well-behaved fans gentle
chivalry marks the introduction and then comes
the kickoff brother this is legalized murder
though forward passes allowed and no
substitutions just vigorous healthy pond
oops sorry old chap didn't see you standing
there after every game there's only one
question in the mind of every player where's
that liniment bottle yes rugby is rugged
this charming pastime is known as soccer
and it's played all over the world
one thing about this game a man can really use his
head one way or another if you have bones of iron
I'm free and you never get winded then soccer
is for you of course you'll have to abide
by the rules and remember no hands allowed
you'll make a score for my dead body buddy
well
if there was ever a game of footsie this is it
Those underpins of his have a college education
in case you're wondering what he's doing he's
dribbling the ball down toward the goal just
like in basketball try it sometime it'll reduce
your waistline in a hurry say here's a switch you
take an outdoor game like soccer bring it indoors
and what have you got that's right indoor soccer
the object of course is to put this exciting ball
game in direct competition with basketball even
if we do lose a few players this way and while
we're on the subject of basketball let's begin
with the youngest exponents of this four boys
as you can see basketball fever gets him at
an early age catching a guard takes Talent
and these fledglings have plenty to spare
it's not so far from diapers to basketball shorts
by the time basketballers reach manhood they're
tricky treatment with the ball would make a
magician turn green with envy when the renowned
Harlem Globetrotters take the court it's a treat
this is what they mean when they say
the hand is quicker than the eye then
that basketball will bear watching under
expert control it becomes a thing alive
but the fans haven't seen anything yet once the
contest begins the Globetrotters turned this
game into a science all this excitement over
who's doing what where but that's basketball
build-up a leading scorer then freeze
the ball if you can exhausting isn't it
as the players tire that basket
seems to be getting smaller and
smaller and the ball keeps getting
heavier and heavier maybe that's
not a basketball of all it feels more
like a medicine ball it's a great game
next we come to water polo although sometimes we
wonder why because this is one of the toughest
games in the book maybe the players don't
get water on the knee in this ball game but
you can hold your opponent under water till he
drowns unless he turns loose the ball without
gills a guy can't breathe down there and
besides I'd rather breathe and score any day
we don't score soon we'll all
be water love let me out of here
ladies tube is sport themselves and mermaid
fashion with a goal at underwater basketball
it's a nice clean sport and mighty
pleasing to the eye besides it gives
us a chance to make movies of the girls
even underwater the referee has the last
word wait somebody is turning blue so the
referee signals and it's a way with a ball